[Music]
hello everyone I'm Nev niku and this is
a gear we're here today to talk about
FUBU TV and how they become a great
streaming provider in under 24 months
with Google cloud so just a little more
background I'm a customer engineer with
Google cloud in New York and the media
entertainment division so we're focused
with partnering with media entertainment
clients I come from doing this in the
on-premise world and then moving to
cloud so kind of have a good background
in this space I don't know oh and I'm
the CTO of FUBU TV come to this from its
advertising background in a video
background if you remember a company
called juiced some number years ago we
were trying something similar so just a
quick agenda today we're gonna go a
little bit into a kind of video
distribution different problems and
considerations that we see in the market
today then we kind of talked about
Google clouds offerings to that there's
a couple different solution pathways
that we can go and then we'll talk about
kind of Foo boat and their case study
and kind of their approach to streaming
and go into you know how they were
successful what their architecture is
best practices and kind of talk about
their timelines the current date and
then some exciting stuff that they're
gonna be doing this year and moving
forward so
so why is live video so difficult how
many people here have watched any type
of video stream and it's been buffering
and you've waited on either a phone a
browser yeah I would say everyone right
so like why those that haven't have you
just not looked at video on the Internet
yeah so this is this is a really hard
problem to solve actually and there's a
lot of things to consider so just real
quick to kind of level set and kind of
get a good picture of what's going on so
with live live video distribution right
there's kind of these different
components that you have so first you
have to actually acquire all of your
different signals right so this can be
via satellite camera fiber right there's
many different ways to do so
then you know you're gonna take that
into an MPEG transport stream and you're
gonna you know do a bunch of processing
encoding transcoding right having your
digital rights management logos that are
needed right and kind of get to get the
video stream ready to actually deliver
then now how do I actually deliver this
globally right so I need a I need a
partner with many CDN providers to then
get getting distribute this to all the
different types of devices right so this
is a really really really really I'll
just keep saying that high level of kind
of the end-to-end video distribution
workflow we'll go into more detail and
technical depth but I just kind of
wanted to set the stage right so what
are kind of all the different things
that we have to consider so this has
been an industry that's been around for
quite a number of years broadcasts right
this has been done via satellite where I
have a set fixed amount of bandwidth and
there's just been new protocols that
have come out you know every five 10
years or so that's basically compressed
the data right so how much how much data
can I fit with a with a fixed bandwidth
rate right now there's many different
devices so that brings a bunch of
different problems and when I'm sending
video over the Internet I have to
account for all the different devices
the different video formats that are
needed based on the device that I have
for the picture quality right and in
that workflow in order to do that
there's so many different partner
that you're gonna have to actually go
through with so like in phobos case
right like they have to require all
these different types of content from
many different providers right so
there's CBS there's Fox there's all the
different sports streams and that's just
on the content part right not even
including the you know who they choose
to partner with on the video processing
side the CDN side etc right so there's
many different parts and many different
companies that are in the entire
workflow that can really you know make
this a pretty tough problem to actually
solve and then not to say how much
bandwidth there is right so there's
different bandwidth that each part in
that workflow and then at the end device
right like I could have really poor
internet because I'm a cheap guy right I
only have 20 megabits per second how am
I gonna get high quality video compared
to somebody who's paying for the one
gigabit line right so there's many many
different problems that we see and then
the coverage area globally right so
there's gonna be people where there's
maybe not infrastructure that is really
best served in that area so how can I
serve someone in you know the middle of
nowhere verse large metropolitan city so
these are all kind of different things
that we have to consider when
distributing live video so where can
Google help so we have the largest cloud
network I had to show the beautiful
scaled slide that you've probably seen
in 15 other different presentations but
in all seriousness we have an extremely
impressive network over a hundred points
of presence and we really we really
think this can help with scaling large
video right we have many different
applications that I'm sure we all use
and so we really think we help with
scale especially with live video
distribution so there's a couple of
different solution pathways that you can
go when trying to solve the problem of
live video distribution so kind of the
spectrum is infrastructure-as-a-service
kinda you see on the left hand side all
the way to kind of software as a service
so we've seen multiple clients and
partners of ours kind of do both it just
kind of depends where you want to turn
the different knobs right so on the
right hand side we have a product suite
called envato which
or video processing and kind of video
processing suite we've seen NBC and CBS
kind of used this before and then on the
Left we see different partners such as
fooball who use our infrastructure as a
service solution set so using different
things like gke compute engine and and
and other other GCP offerings that we've
seen so it just depends infrastructure
as a service gives you kind of the most
flexibility in your deployment right and
you can kind of really control different
parts in the video distribution workflow
whereas software as a service kind of
gives you what you need but you have a
little bit less control on that right
and we kind of see this with a bunch of
cloud offerings today with server lists
right and then also you know compute
engine so there's just different
methodologies that you can do so and I
think that's kind of what makes cloud a
really unique and fun place to be we
kind of give you the tool sets and you
kind of can choose what makes the most
sense for you and your business in your
application so I've kind of set the
stage talking about you know what the
problem is different things that we you
know you have to consider throughout the
video distribution workflow and kind of
the different offerings we think that
GCP can help with now I'm gonna hand it
over to gear kind of talk about you know
fubo their journey on GCP and the reason
that they chose the specific
architecture and different components
that they did this team was getting a
new you thank you to click the signs in
sorry
you want me to click the signs of you go
I can click this line all right if you
can if you want to click this lines no
it's [ __ ] I'm flexible
so um how many of you are cord cutters
that that get your TV consumption not
from your bandwidth provider all right
so some some review marketing always
hates when I do this but how many of you
are fubo customers all right great
great thank you I'm one two
I just look at this as a tremendous
potential for our business right so fubo
is a ott streaming service we are sports
focused we call ourselves the world's
only sports focused it really comes from
our origin as a provider that was
delivering first soccer and I think the
name came from a riff on on football
right what we do is we deliver both live
television and VOD to you and we say
live television these are the channels
that you would get from any other
provider Fox Turner etc sports stations
like like be in sports
you'll get NBCSN NBC stations we have
locals so just your local television
affiliates for for FOX NBC we also have
regional sports nets so I don't know if
like Nessun in Boston or SNY in New York
for your your local sports and it's
available on on pretty much anything
that you would want to show it on we we
are trying to make it really great
in-home experience so you can get it to
your Smart TV or your your various TV
connected devices like an Apple TV or
fire TV but you can also get it on the
web you can also get it on mobile
devices and pretty much anywhere you
want to be as long as it's bandwidth so
a little bit of our back story we'll get
into some technical things in a moment
the original product vision was to
aggregate vo DS for professionals
football clubs or teams is their goal
that's soccer for anyone whose soccer
can yeah sorry it's a this foreign sport
that's really popular what the clubs
were doing is they had their on their
website they would have content specific
to their team so you go to Everton and
you can see you know game replays
highlights interviews backstory kind of
stuff but you know a lot of lot of
soccer fans like multiple teams so what
what fubo was trying to do was bring it
all together one place where you can get
this content for all of soccer
and it didn't quite work because at
least in a market sense because sports
fans like live sports right anybody here
as a sports fan do you tend to want to
watch it live or you're willing to
record it and like watch it next week
life right so so food will had to bring
in live streaming and while VOD is
fairly straightforward because you can
get the asset ahead of time you can
transcode it prepare it you know quality
control make sure it's a good experience
for the consumer and then put it out in
your in your distribution system live is
is kind of a real-time thing right it's
being broadcast and when I say live I'll
also use linear interchangeably for me
live is actually true live when people
are out on a field doing something or
you know like like an award show or
something where it's actually happening
in real time
linear is just the general idea that we
have these streams being broadcast at us
and they need to be delivered as close
to real-time as possible it cannot be in
real time there's latency it's just
physics and architecture kind of forced
this but adding this linear stream
became a really big change for the
business both technically and as well
front from the perspective of the
business and I'll give a little bit of
background on the business we're we're a
cable company right we are no different
in some ways then whoever your cable
provider is we have to license the
content from from the content owners Fox
hallmark whoever and we use that same
business model that that that the cable
companies do which is we have to pay on
a per subscriber basis not what's viewed
but just if we have a quarter million
subscribers we will pay quarter two
hundred thousand times whatever the
person scriber fee is and this makes a
pretty tough business because a lot of
money goes into purchasing the content
or licensing the content I mean in fact
in our business we don't quite even
break even on subscriber fees subscriber
fees plus a little bit more are given
all to the content owners and our
business is about making it up from
advertising and and other content
upsells
on the technology side and this is what
we're gonna go into in a moment
adding linear it was a really big
difference right there's the plane is
always in the air right you can never
stop
you can never pause it just has to work
and we're competing with the system that
you know has you know over 70 years of
development behind it and is fairly
stable right when you turn on your
television on a sort of a legacy
distribution system it works and it
works really well and for us to be
successful we have to deliver that kind
of consumer experience without owning
the infrastructure without owning the
path the network path to the user and
it's it's a bit of a trick apparently my
slide changed itself
so why is this hard I think it's because
we're all figuring it out right
certainly the content owners our
partners are figuring it out we are a
different kind of place for content to
be pushed to we have different
requirements we're in different places
right we don't have satellite downlink
infrastructure we don't have broadcast
centers we are in the cloud right signal
acquisition partners are people who
specialized in transport of getting it
from the content partner to the cloud
right
they are also figuring it out because
again it's kind of a new thing to get
into the cloud into and to integrate
with these with these other parties our
cloud partners are figuring it out right
we do a kind of workload that isn't very
common in cloud environments some people
think it's a little crazy to do in a
cloud environment but with the
variability and multi-tenancy that
you're gonna run into but we make it
work
CDN partners same thing we're certainly
figuring it out and then consumers also
are part of the chain they are
effectively part of the distribution
system in that they're in-home networks
are part of the delivery path they the
different kinds of devices that they
that they would need to be able to have
a good ott experience is also something
new to them
we'll get the technical stuff in a
moment our timeline is we were founded
in 2015 entirely soccer focused we
talked about how we went to VOD adding
the linear but that really wasn't a
success in the market either because
soccer in any sport is sort of limited
in terms of time and limited in terms of
interest right you have your season
baseball season I guess which seems to
go on forever like like hockey but
football seasons in the fall early
winter soccer season is limited so what
we needed to do is to make it something
that you would subscribe to and keep all
year round we had to add other content
the slide keeps changing I don't know
why but yet
if I just keep jumping so we added FOX
NBC we're at at CBS
so now starting to produce a content
package that's really for the whole
family we launched advance DVR which is
kind of a table stakes if you're gonna
have a TT service
hit a hundred thousand subscribers by
the end of 2017 really focus now on on
building a business out of it by adding
server-side ad insertion which is sort
of the main monetization driver for the
business what we do is on every stream
that's coming to every single user
they're all individual streams and were
able to insert advertising on a per user
per stream basis we'll talk about that a
little bit later apparently it's a big
event that I joined the place but I've
been there for about a year we were the
first to do 4k streaming OTT and we did
it with the World Cup which was which
was last year that's a large event
played mostly by foreigners soccer how
many people are soccer fans okay so a
couple in football and soccer we're
gonna interchange that just we're not
confusing anyone so we have a
international strategy we launched into
Spain and then where we keep adding new
content to the package so how many
people know how streaming really works
it's it's not a continuous stream of
bits being sent at you right it is
really a series of files that are just
being loaded over and and buffered and
then played at you so I'm gonna give
this as a background talking about
something called HTTP Live Streaming
it's a fairly simple protocol some would
argue one that should never have made it
out of the the design room right but the
way it works is you have a source
usually it's a pretty fat source 30
megabits a second 50 megabits a second
depending on the quality of it it is
encoded and why that means is we take
that that sort of mezzanine feed and we
turn it into multiple bit rates so there
may be a 10 megabit stream a 7 a 5 a 3-1
750 K whatever you choose to do is sort
of the variant
it's called and the reason why you do
that is it allows the player to based on
the trouble that's having loading
content switch to different bit rates to
keep continuity of the stream you're
going to lose quality as the bitrate
goes down but you at least get a at
least get the experience
now what encoding is doing it's creating
little files that are called manifests
it's a text file that is a list of the
next series of video segments that are
to be played by the player and then
video segments are just chunks of video
that are being produced and then dropped
into storage so these would be say
that's three buckets somewhere or I
guess I misspelled pulldown actually I
misspelled that right yes yes that's so
what the players doing is the players
going to ask for a manifest they'll say
give me the next manifest takes the
manifest and then starts loading the
video segments and when it has enough of
them it'll start the playback but then
it keeps this process going while the
video is playing asking for the next
manifest every four seconds it asks for
a manifest and these manifest keep
getting updated as new chunks are being
created off the encoder and playback
occurs right so this is fundamentally
how HLS works and dash is very similar
it's a different different standard but
it's basically give me the list of
things to do start playing it
keep fetching keep giving me the list
and so on I'm a palang cue for your
explanation yeah so yeah as a call-outs
I mean I feel like I should be selling
something here on the floor anyway so
the you know the the obligatory how this
maps into Google services slide
ingestion is is on the networking
infrastructure google has an excellent
networking infrastructure so we bring a
lot of streams right in to us that way
we do the the encoding or the
transcoding using google compute we are
dropping into multiple storages for
redundancy multiple regions and then a
delivery network such as you know Google
CDN is used to front the the origins and
devices pull in the the way we just
described with the HLS lesson
now it's what we do is a little more
complicated than than the previous slide
there's a couple of pieces of this we've
got sort of third-party inputs that
would be content is the biggest one
right there's there's some content
providers up there we get metadata
because as part of any television you
want to have a guide like electronic
program guide so we need to get that
information and that comes from a
company called grace note Tribune Media
Services is the subsidiary there's other
kinds of data sources that can come in
and then there's third-party services
that we use for mainly sort of non core
things such as subscription management
and payments more on that in a sec then
inside this big grey box is really what
we do we have if you can think of the
platform divides into couple of pieces
there's video management and delivery
there is sort of program data and
discovery and then program comma data
and discovery and then user and
subscription management are the three
big chunks and then there's finally the
client applications that we also build
so we build apps for for mobile we're
web obviously and then we're building
Smart TV app Samsung is about to be
released in beta in the next couple of
weeks and then Apple TV the pucks as I
call them Apple TV Roku the sticks fire
TV whatever so
what we're doing is actually a lot more
complicated than the original hls slide
for a bunch of reasons first of all we
have permissioning and licensing to
worry about and not only is it are you
allowed to access content at all but
it's very specifically what content and
a lot of this is based where you are the
two things that fold into this or that
the primary thing that folds into it is
sports rights management sports are
interesting in that sometimes depending
on the sport you're allowed to see your
home team when you're away right so if
you're a New Yorker and you're here in
San Francisco I think with baseball it's
called couch rights meaning where your
couch is so if your couches in New York
you can see anything your couch can see
no matter where you are I think NFL has
something called Hotel rules whereas
wherever you physically are so I
couldn't I was would say I couldn't
watch the New York Jets but like why
would I hey hey I'm on you're a Jets fan
yes yes sorry this is actually bigger
than the talk we actually found a Jets
fan yeah yeah that's a that's quite you
know the joke about just like the Mets
right there's a big sign in New York it
was you know welcome to New York home of
nine professional sports teams and also
the Mets so one of the things we have to
do is where you are create streams that
that switch based on this rights
management stuff right so and this is
we're gonna go into a little bit of
depth when we're creating a video stream
it's actually a personalized stream for
you every time the player is asking for
that manifest we're not just serving it
something out of a out of a CDN what
we're doing is a rights check we know
who you are and then we based on
switching information that we have on
the incoming streams synthesize a
channel for you based on whatever your
rights are or whatever you're supposed
to see so every four seconds we do a
computation for you we get what the
manifests are for whatever streams could
be contributing to what your channel is
and then we write out a manifest
specifically for you and return that
so that's really what we talk about we
say the real time video extreme
construction and we'll go to that into
some depth we have to manage DVRs
that's a talk unto itself the rights
metadata is what I was referring to is
how we construct these streams encoding
and storage we do some delivery
optimization what we can do is because
we're also as we're writing this
manifest we have the option of choosing
where you get the segment from right so
if if Google CDN is the the most
responsive where you are at that moment
we might write the URLs to pull the
segment's out of Google CDN but if you
were maybe fastly was better for you we
then use fastly right so this gives us
the ability to optimize the consumer
experience to go for the lowest latency
possible it also gives us the ability to
easily steer around a CDN when there's a
failure and you know like everything
else they fail program data and discard
program comma data and discovery we do a
lot in search and personalization it's
something that we've been really focused
on and its really a area of main focus
for us in the consumer experience going
forward we get this metadata scheduled
metadata and we have to process it
normalize it and then make it available
to the front ends as well as internal
systems for channel construction and
then subscriber data and in user
management we're a subscription business
direct-to-consumer we have to take
credit cards we have to do you know the
billing we use Recurly for that but but
that's that section and the only thing
I'll add is like when I was talking
about all the different partners and
components like if you look at this
slide and just the number like the
number of people the number of companies
that are needed like this kind of just
puts it in perspective like on that
slide that I showed how much actually
goes into this and we're gonna go in a
technical depth on kind of certain
components but this kind of I think puts
into perspective like how tough this is
and how many moving parts there are and
it gets worse when you add advertising
right because at this point you're
producing video stream and then you've
got to put a layer of advertising to
personalize each stream
so you know we use GCP stuff for it a
Google conference we are primarily
Google cloud and always have been it's
the wizard it's the magical wizard I
thought it was the I thought it was the
I thought I just trying to move us along
here so we use I'm kind of averse
personally to sort of the more advanced
proprietary offerings that you find in a
cloud provider honestly so fundamentally
were there for the compute network and
storage which we find is excellent right
it's really good stuff we do use
kubernetes right I think the nono talk
here would be complete without somebody
mentioning kubernetes we do use bigquery
that is one of those proprietary
technologies that we made the decision
to go with it's excellent it is sort of
the core engine behind everything we do
with search personalization metrics
analytics we use cloud store for the
video segments we have a lot of stories
about that because it is a
general-purpose storage and as you can
imagine we want to be able to get the
video segments as we receive them from
the encoder to disk as fast as possible
so we don't lose them but at the same
time they have to be available for
reading immediately right because it's a
live stream so we're very sensitive to
the latency there and then we also use
datastore as a really for manifests and
historical manifest storage so I'm not
gonna talk about this again
I just wanted to as a reminder how HLS
works what we've done is we've taken
that previous diagram and made it a
little more complicated because of this
idea that we have to be synthesizing
channels based on a bunch of factors one
factor I didn't mention is especially if
it's important with sports is the
concept of overtime right nobody can
predict how long a game is really going
to go in any sport that allows overtime
so very often what we have to do and
most people are watching with acceptive
things like BN where you're getting
sports specific channels a lot of people
consume their sports on your local
affiliate right you're at your local NBC
here in San Francisco and they have a
schedule that comprises local local
programming which might be like source
number one and then there's the national
feed it should be source number two and
and what we have to do is we need to we
have what's called study signaling
information that tell us when to switch
between streams so you may have local
programming up to the start of a
baseball game and then you switch to the
national feed to get the baseball game
and then you might have to switch back
once the game is theoretically over
because then there's Judge Judy or
whatever shown but when you have
overtime or extended play like an extra
innings this becomes a problem because
you do not want to switch back to Judge
Judy when the game is going into
overtime because that's usually the most
exciting part of a game and it produces
tremendous amounts of ire from your
customers like true true hate right
nothing is worse than say dropping off
like the third overtime in a hockey game
and switching back to the original
programming they they will come after
you so we have these multiple encoding
streams that were storing and what's
happening is this playlist decisioning
system is using some of this metadata to
decide which source to give you when you
ask for a channel so in terms of a flow
the players saying to an authorization
service hey can i watch this and here's
my credentials and and the the auth
service gives it a token back says sure
here give this to the playlist service
the player will then ask the playlist
decisioning system i give me give me my
manifest for this channel the player
decisioning system will will based on
where you are in time and what's
supposed to be happening choose the
source stream and provide a manifest to
you that tells you what the segments are
next it can also rewrite the urls to get
them so we can choose among a set of CD
ends that we work with which CDN is
going to deliver to you and then the
player says all right give me the
segments to the right CDN the CDN then
gets it from origin that's not that
interesting that part and then you know
lather rinse and repeat you ask for your
next manifest
the the playlist decisioning system can
choose a different stream based on
whatever is really supposed to you're
supposed to see and then you may choose
even a different CDN because something
happened with the first CDN that you
were using right so this is really how
we produce streams and if you think
about it it means that every single
stream that we produce is unique right I
mean they're gonna look the same but
they are in theory unique because we are
computing them specifically for given a
given player now this is a business
where we take all the money that the
consumers give us and and then we take
some other money that we get from either
advertising or VCS and we give it all to
the content owners right this is not in
itself a sustainable business model it's
it's a very difficult business so where
the financials come in is really
advertising is the core monetization for
the company and it too is an interesting
technical problem I used to be the CEO
of app in exes when I left AppNexus I
thought okay I've done my time in
advertising I will never go back to this
and I find now that really most of my
attention is being spent on advertising
and Google knows nothing about
advertising so sorry we don't know
anything about advertise right and as
Google
yeah don't don't ask about that division
of the company we're here to talk about
cloud right right as we said it's every
video stream is is unique and
independent and that gives us the
ability to produce advertising that is
unique and independent for each user
right this is kind of the the holy grail
for advertisers is to be able to target
you specifically and it's going to be
watched right unlike al I say web web
display where most of it is below the
fold anyway this is something your TV's
up there right and this is not a
distracting thing in the corner I mean
I'm not gonna apologize it for as how
television works but at some point you
go to a commercial break and the
commercials are shown so these are ads
that are shown right there's humans that
watch them so we can determine in real
time and this is not a new concept for
anybody that has been doing advertising
in the last ten years but for television
it's kind of a new idea and honestly the
television buyers the people who are
buying advertising for television don't
get it yet right they don't really
understand that we can target to the
individual user so how does it work
technically so if you remember what we
talked about before the player talked to
the playlist service which gets
manifests and the cycle continues what
we do is we put an ad stitcher in front
and what an ad stitcher looks like it's
just a proxy in some ways and when the
player asks for manifests the ads
picture goes to the playlist service
since manifest is produced and it's
returned now as it's coming back what to
get an advertisement there are cue
points there might be a little line in
the manifest that says queue out here
and you can do it for 60 seconds that's
a 60-second ad break now there still is
gonna be video segments listed those are
the video segments on the original
stream right so that would actually be
the advertisement that the content
owners say CNN has on their channel but
as part of the agreement we have with
the content owners they give us some
amount of time per hour say 1 to 2
minutes 2 to 3 minutes so when we get
our ad break what will happen then is
media tailor will look at the manifest
the ads pitcher looks at the manifest
sees that an ad break is coming and then
it makes an ad call and it calls we have
a proxy because we didn't want to
connect we wanted to be able to be have
some control over in real time where
we're calling which ad server we want to
work with and logging and all sorts of
stuff it's obviously a good idea to do
and what we do is we choose among a set
of ad servers or ad partners freewheel
you've probably heard of it's a owned by
Comcast it's a it's a very popular very
big video ad server spring serve is a
lesser-known
about an excellent ad server and ApS is
Amazon's publishing system they they do
buying and then the ad servers talk to
you know basically SSPs or other demand
partners who figure out who has an ad
and wants that specific person or that
specific device or whatever then the ad
slot is filled up with ads
basically links to ads and that whole
pile is then sent back up to media
tailor to the ad stitcher now these are
mp4s right they can't actually be
inserted in an HLS stream because HLS
has multiple variants at different bit
rates what the that stitcher has to do
is take the advertisements that came
back from the from the the ad
decisioning side of things it has to
transcode it has to turn them into the
same variant rates that we have the main
streams on which means that for the
first time it ever sees an advertisement
it can't show it right because it hasn't
transcoded you can tree trance code them
that fast so it trance codes them puts
it into a CDN and remembers that it's
transcoded that ad so the next time that
ad comes through which it will the ad is
ready to play and it rewrites the
manifest so that instead of getting the
video chunks that are from the
underlying streams of CNN it actually
then just gives video chunks that are
advertising chunks right so it's a
seamless process the player generally
doesn't know what's going on there
there's some variance to that you can do
sometimes the player can do beaconing as
well but fundamentally from a playback
perspective the player has no idea it's
just getting video segments video
segments video segments video segments
happen to switch from original content
video segment to advertising segment and
then when there's a cue in basically the
the it's where the the playlist service
is saying all right ad break is over you
got to go back to content then media
tailor stops doing anything and just
just keeps me flowing through and that's
really how a server-side ad stitching
works fairly simple in theory but a lot
of moving parts a lot of lot of things
that can go wrong if any of you have
have worked with advertising
technologies they can be a mess and
these aren't so I think that was it in
terms of the overall tech part of things
yeah and I guess the only thing I'll say
is like all of that that he just
explained happens in between when you
literally the game is on and then goes
to halftime like that that like little
blip all of that literally happens in
the backend just to serve you the
correct add so like it's a very very
quick process that needs to happen in
order to stitch all that together to
serve you that advertisement so I hope I
don't know if it's just me it's a really
really hard problem that happens super
super fast like he explained that over
five ten minutes and that happens in
life like that so it's just a put in
perspective kind of like all the moving
pieces to do that sorry
so in terms of best practices you know
we've been on this journey for a couple
of years we did what people we didn't do
what people normally do which is do
on-prem so they can control everything
as you can imagine we're really
sensitive to network we're really
sensitive to compute we're really
sensitive to storage latency but we did
it all in the cloud and I guess we have
some best practices that we've learned
and I'll say together because honestly
Google when you're working with the
cloud provider like this they are your
operations team or part of your
operations team whether you realize it
or not and our relationship is to the
point where it really is a partnership I
mean that's really the last point here
is is they're not just a vendor right it
you shouldn't treat them like a vendor
if it's something core to your business
and they shouldn't treat you like a
customer or just a customer right you
need to sort of be part of the same team
we have weekly calls that they
participate with us and with other third
parties that we work with because we're
so sensitive to things like network
their networking team is on the call it
is not just the the usual front facing
customer engineers we can get deep into
their teams because they have a vested
interest in us succeeding other ideas is
that look these says cloud systems are
built for general purpose use they're
not built for us right they're built for
thousands of customers multi-tenancy
wide range of workloads
so you know test your use case right
it's kind of obvious we're very
sensitive to latency and we have to
design around some of the uncertainty in
latency that we see in these cloud-based
systems
cloud systems behavior her subject to
change
sometimes just due to failure but that's
not that interesting because everything
fails sometimes it feels like the
system's actually changed their their
behavioral properties based on on I
guess load like we've seen normally have
no problem with hotkeys in a datastore
and all of a sudden he's become hotkeys
and latency increases or fail right
these are things you just have to be
aware of will happen and it's due to
other activities within the cloud
because these are shared systems and
then this idea for proprietary
technology choose carefully right
because what is a quick win today like
oh let me just use that because it's
quick and I can get the system up is you
know next year's tech debt and it's
sometimes awfully hard to back out of
these things
we made a decision to go with bigquery
I'm very happy with it it is a
proprietary lock in kind of thing we are
kind of stuck we're not unhappy we don't
want to go but if you think about what
it would take to move all of this data
out of out of Google into somewhere else
it's not a problem even when I think
about
III I think there's you money thing to
add on that I think I think like what's
what was just to kind of bring the point
home was we when we get on like we have
these weekly calls right like what is
that weekly call there's gonna be like
many different people that are always
involved right like all those partners
that you saw will have multiple calls
with different partners and it's just
like really being aware of like the
different services that are like
segmented and who's all involved and
where and I think just being like an AMA
tan honest open transparent kind of you
know not to be cliche but DevOps II and
you know kind of culture and environment
really helped I think like make us
successful together because we
understand that there's all these moving
pieces and all these you know different
parts and partners that are involved and
it's just about like kind of like
together like solving this problem and
understanding where each each piece fits
and I think like it really really helped
us like really both be success yeah and
move really fast so I mean I think there
are Google engineers that spend more
time talking with some of our technical
partners than I do
yeah it's true and I think it's great
because
they are world-class experts and the
things they're working on and they can
really get to the root of a problem when
when there is one and there are problems
right there yeah
there always will be I miss our future
we're trying to bring key core services
in-house we will continue to build more
new things on the Google platform you
know multi-cloud it's amazing that the
marketing people let this through but
it's one of the things we're doing
mainly driven by external forces that
there are there are content streams that
are coming into other cloud environments
not to Google and we have to go over
there to be able to receive them and
encode them and then then we can bring
things over we're gonna continue
investing in personalization more
markets not just Spain and then
apparently there's something I know that
he doesn't which we're gonna put
anything exciting yeah I'm not gonna
tell all right so we have to wait and
see that's it that's it we left a little
less than 10 minutes eight minutes it
says for any questions that you might
have if you could do the feedback we
really appreciate it I think it's really
important so we can kind of make sure if
there's any anything to fix change we
love love honest feedback if you have
any questions the mics are there lineup
will be here about yeah seven eight
minutes left so we appreciate your time
like I got one question on DVR how are
you dealing with massive parallel DVR
recording lots of storage it's it's a
big expense but but we have the I mean
you think about what a DVR recording is
in the cloud right we we have all the
segments they land right because we're
we're taking them off the encoders and
putting them in the DVR process happens
in the background and makes copies right
it's it's that's really how it works and
it's a large storage cost for us we use
different tiers of storage for this
purpose right because unlike the the
front the first line of storage for the
CDN origins which have to be fast which
they were faster DVR doesn't have to be
as fast you can accept some latency when
somebody hits play on a DVR it can be
pulled out of the sort of the Nearline
storage and start playing google has a
Envato service that checks a lot of the
same boxes why not use them instead they
have a suite of services they have an
encoding service right they have I think
have an ad stitcher they don't do what
we do they don't have the rights
management they don't handle the things
that we needed to do to be able to
license this content and distribute it
right like these kind of services like
envato are and they were there pointed
out on the original slide by content
owners right if I'm NBC yeah like I know
exactly what I'm gonna do and don't have
to worry about licensing in the way in
the same way we do because they are the
ones that are putting the licensing
constraints on us so I think it's a good
set of building blocks we had to do
something different fundamentally with
playlist generation and then honestly
given how sensitive we are to a good
video experience we are trying to do
more and more things like encoding
in-house so if at least if something
goes wrong it's our fault and it's um
we can fix if it's a third-party
provider it's not a lot you can do
sometimes
mr. Clara just to clarify a couple icons
on the slide I'm guessing that you use
GCS for video segment data storage but I
was curious what you use for the video
stream metadata storage if that's GCS or
if it's faster or you mean like anyway
the manifests you have a manifest yeah
so the manifests are they they go into
datastore right now because we need them
time ordered right we are switching to a
different system which again preserves
that time order we think it's going to
be a basically if you think about Kafka
is a time ordered list of stuff that is
permanent until you roll it off the back
it's it that that solves that problem as
well so we do it that way so switch into
Kafka car then we are we are testing a
solution that is based on a large Kafka
cluster I mean it's a flat load input
right because you've got 800 channels or
a thousand channels they have a
completely predictable and stable load
so that's actually easy to ingest in
store and the variable load is on the on
the the the output so how many people
concurrent streams are coming in and
it's an easy problem for something like
Kafka because you confront it with a
cache in front that keeps say the last
15 minutes of manifest in memory and if
everybody's watching the exact same
program it's not a problem you're just
pulling it at around thanks
how did you get a server-side connection
DFP to do your ad stitching on the
four-year proxy sorry I missed the
question say again what did you have to
do to get a server-side connection to
DFP to include their ads in your
stitching on your server side we just so
what happens is the ad server the what
happens is that stitcher makes the ad
call to us it goes to an ad server just
a conventional ad video ad server and
that makes a call to something like DFP
so that might be somebody is buying roku
like they really want to buy Roku
impressions they give us tags that come
from DF P's ad server we are our ad
server we'll call that just to see hey
do you want this and it'll return either
avast or not that all gets packaged
together in return so it's not like
there's a connection between the ad
stitcher and the demand partners
directly the ad server is making the
calls to the demand partners and going
back we don't use DFP as our ad server
hello are you currently using or have
plans to use any machine learning
services for content delivery or ad
delivery we're experimenting on both of
those it's primarily in the area of sort
of recommendation and similar but there
are some interesting uses for detection
of advertisement detection of sentiment
to understand what's happening in a game
if we could automatically know a game is
going into overtime by understanding
what the game action is or the clock or
the scoreboard it would make our lives a
lot simpler although it's a fairly
sophisticated way to do it versus just
having somebody watch it and hit a
button
hey if you have a critical failure in
the ad pipeline what does the experience
look like for the customer do you try
and fail in favor of them or sorry in
which pipeline so this this whole ad
pipeline here the thing that delivers
the the adverts to the customer in some
kind of break yeah if if they saw some
kind of critical failure and you can't
deliver those ads what does the
experience look like for the customer ah
this is actually the best failure mode
we have because if you remember we're so
you're watching CNN right
CNN goes into an ad break there's CNN
ads there CNN is putting advertising
there it's it's the same stream you get
on TV so if there's a failure to deliver
to get an advertisement or to transcode
the advertisement then just the
underlying stream just plays and the
user has no idea something happened
that's assuming the a stitcher doesn't
do something really stupid but that
generally doesn't
well it's your ads stitcher having to
decode and re-encode so that it can yeah
yeah so when an advertisement is first
seen so suppose it's a 30-second ad for
Ford something I don't know it has a
unique identifier it's usually just the
URL for it for the mp4 and media Taylor
keeps a list of all the advertisements
that it knows about and has encoded if
it's not on that list it will run a
trance code process in the same way we
transcode the the incoming stream turn
it into the bitrate variance that we're
using so that it can be slotted right
into whatever bitrate stream the player
is playing right that means of course
that the first time an ad is seen by the
ad stitcher it cannot be played to the
user and that's a case where there is
that failure mode we we just don't show
an ad and the underlying stream is
playing but and I should have drawn it
I'm sorry there should have been a
little loop here saying this is where
the encoding happens but then once it
has it it's cached it can it can serve
that ad next time decisioning system
says show that
[Music]